foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is Dom cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
number one best-selling author Ramsay
personality Christina Ellis is my
co-host today on this special
Thanksgiving edition of the Ramsey show
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five if you've
never been around us on Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving among many other
opportunities around here we pretty much
believe in being a cheese factory
we like cheese and we like being cheesy
and
um it's you know we own the show so we
get to do whatever slip we want to do
with it so that's what we do so if you
didn't know there was a lady named Sarah
Josephina Hale in the 1800s that ran a a
magazine of sorts called goodies ladies
book and of course it was all things for
ladies and what to do in the kitchen and
so forth in the 1800s she also is noted
with having composed or written the
nursery rhyme Mary had a little lamb she
was very famous in the 1800s and for 30
years every year she wrote to the
president of the United States asking
them to set aside a certain day
nationally for Thanksgiving different
states had thanksgivings George
Washington had asked for a date of
Thanksgiving but there was not an
official holiday of Thanksgiving
finally after 30 years the president in
1863 Abraham Lincoln
decided that she was right
and went to the Secretary of State
William Seward which was a bit of an
enemy of his but was on his cabinet they
were kind of crossing swords all the
time but Seward was a quite a Wordsmith
and asked him to create the proclamation
making this a holiday I read it every
Thanksgiving on the air because it's
important for you folks to remember how
this nation
should operate used to
operate this is from the president
of the United States October 3rd 1863
the year that is drawing towards its
close has been filled with the blessings
of fruitful fields and healthful skies
to these bounties which are so
constantly enjoyed that we are prone to
forget the source from which they come
others have been added which are of so
extraordinary a nature that they cannot
fail to penetrate and even soften the
heart which is habitually insensible to
the ever watchful Providence
of almighty God
in the midst of a civil war of unequaled
magnitude and severity which is
sometimes seemed to foreign states to
invite him to provoke their aggression
peace has been preserved with all
nations order has been maintained the
laws have been respected and obeyed and
Harmony has prevailed everywhere except
in the theater of military conflict
while that theater has been greatly
contracted by the advancing armies and
navies of the Union needful diversions
of wealth and of strength from the
fields of peaceful industry to the
National Defense have not arrested the
plow the shuttle or the ship the acts
has enlarged the borders of our
settlements and the minds as well of
iron and coal as of the precious metals
have yielded even more abundantly than
heretofore population has steadily
increased notwithstanding the waste that
has been made in the camp The Siege and
the battlefield and the country
rejoicing in the consciousness of
augmented strength and vigor is
permitted to expect continuance of years
with large increase of freedom
no human counsel hath devised nor hath
any mortal hand worked out these great
things
they are the gracious gifts of the most
high God
who while dealing with us in Anger for
our sins had nevertheless remembered
Mercy
it has seen fit it seemed to be fit and
proper that they should be solemnly
reverently and gratefully acknowledged
as with one heart and one voice by the
whole American people I do therefore
invite my fellow citizens in every part
of the United States and also those who
are at Sea and those who are sojourning
in foreign lands to set apart and
observe the last Thursday of November
next as a as a day of Thanksgiving and
praise
to our beneficent father who dwelleth in
the heavens
and I recommend to them that while
offering up the ascriptions justly due
to him for such singular deliverances
and blessings that they also with humble
pentatives for our national perverseness
and Disobedience commend to his Tender
Care all those who have become widows
orphans mourners or sufferers in the
lamentable civil Strife in which we are
in unaffordable unavoidably engaged and
fervently implore interposition of the
almighty hand
to heal the wounds of the nation
and to restore it as soon as may be
consistent with the Divine purposes to
the full enjoyment of Peace Harmony
tranquility and Union in testimony
wherever I've heretofore set my hand and
cause the seal the United States to be
effect
to be affixed done this
um done at the city of Washington this
third day of October the year of Our
Lord
1863 President Abraham Lincoln
oh wow that's powerful I if it doesn't
make you regardless of your party
affiliation yearn for someone of that
level of character to actually show up
anywhere on the landscape
and and even just drive by the White
House
uh wow
wow it's uh yeah this is this kind of uh
humility
um and uh
acceptance and observance that in case
you didn't know the Thanksgiving is not
about worshiping turkey and football by
the way it's about saying thank you Lord
thank you God
according to Abraham Lincoln who made
this the holiday so let me just go to
the source this is what he's saying he's
very clear here that this this holiday
is about us stopping for a moment
I guess we could call it a religious
holiday because we're supposed to say
thank you to the Lord for the blessings
that he's given us that's what the
holiday was put in place for now you
cannot like that or whatever but that's
the them's the facts ma'am
um so this is the way it is and
pretty cool uh and you've got to love
the language oh my goodness if anyone
spoke like that today you'd be looking
at them cross-eyed like they walked out
of a time machine but uh because we're
all like we're all about yeah huh what
so OMG you know the the use of language
is just completely
gorgeous and I mean it's just fabulous
I'm not a writer and I and I wouldn't
want to sit and read that the type of uh
lingo for three hours my eyes were
crossed but uh but isn't it beautiful
it's beautiful and just a reminder of
what they were going through then and
how grateful they were in the middle of
the Civil War right it's perspective wow
stop and say thank you Lord
so your ticket on the air today if you
want to talk about your life and your
money we're here to help put your ticket
on the air is what are you thankful for
and cheese factories invited
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five eight eight two
five five two two five
[Music]
[Music]
is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more births
[Music]
[Music]
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today Lacey is with us in
Indianapolis hi Lacey welcome to the
Ramsey Show
what's up Happy Thanksgiving wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute I
gotta get I gotta get in my zone here
before I let you on the air what are you
thankful for
oh I'm so thankful for my parents and um
what a Godly relationship they have and
that they've pointed me to Christ so
very cool I like that one good okay
what's up
so my parents my wonderful parents have
come to me recently
um and asked to pay off my mortgage
um I have about 55 000 left on my home I
am completely debt free other than that
I am a single 32 year old teacher and
they are everyday millionaires they
follow your your uh advice and
um it wouldn't be a gift it would be me
paying them back but instead of owing
the bank I would owe them at a lower
interest rate
um I know you don't love mixing family
and money and all of those things but I
I didn't know what your thoughts were on
this
um I have a great relationship with them
but I'm very hesitant also you have
siblings
I do I have a brother
okay
um
I will make a suggestion before I say
don't do this
[Laughter]
instead instead I would recommend they
just make it a gift
and reduce your portion of the
inheritance by that so that your brother
is not cheated
okay now here's the reason
um a you're not a spoiled brat they're
not um they're not you know they're not
making your life too easy they're just
taking they're just using some of their
wealth to perpetuate wealth in their
family tree by making you 100 debt free
as a teacher at 32 which leads you in a
millionaire status very quickly right
yes okay so that's what I would do if I
were them and I would never loan my kids
money and here is why
100 of the time
you mentioned your faith uh the Bible
says it never there's no caveat it
doesn't say except for Mom and Dad it
says the borrower is slave to the lender
and so 100 of the time no matter how
nice your master is
no matter how good your master is you're
still a slave no matter how kind they
are how functional they are how good
their boundaries are you are still a
slave and you will feel it as John as
John deloney says in your body your body
will keep score and and you'll know this
when Thanksgiving dinner tastes
different when you eat with your master
rather than your mama
yeah that was what I was afraid of and I
I was hesitant as well I just wanted to
hear and it's not you and it's not you
being ungrateful and I'm not trying to
talk them into if they don't want to do
it at all that's fine too you have a
mortgage you're okay you're not dying
you're everything's good but but um I
just don't want you have such a
wonderful and you you outlined it three
different times great relationship with
them I wouldn't want to take a chance on
that
absolutely absolutely do you think
they'll be resistant at all to just
giving you the money versus lending it
nice and
um they have gifted my brother and I
both smaller portions of money in the
past just as gifts to say like put this
towards your mortgage or put it toward
whatever you need
um and and they've been very generous in
that and they're very equal right this
is this is going to be weird for you so
let's change the conversation let me
give you a tool okay
blame me
whoa okay no I'm saying because if you
go to them and say Mom and Dad I got
this great idea why don't you give me
the money instead that's just that's
awkward right yeah that's weird so just
say hey I called Dave and he said don't
do the mortgage
and
um he said the only way he would do it
if it was his kids would be to give it
and if you don't I don't want you to I
don't want to ask you for that but
that's what Dave said I feel like that's
a pretty big pass yeah just throw it up
throw it off on me I can handle it
yeah so when when my mom calls in Dave
you be ready oh I'll be absolutely ready
I'll I'll be I'll be kind to her but I
will tell her the truth like I always do
Happy Thanksgiving Lacey appreciate you
calling in very cool stuff all right uh
Craig is in New York City hi Craig Happy
Thanksgiving what are you thankful for
hey David Christina it's a pleasure to
be on the air Happy Thanksgiving sure
what are you thankful for I'm most
thankful for uh you know Jesus Christ
changing my life amen and amen all right
how can we help today
all right so yeah I'm 24 years old
um you know my whole life I was told to
buy a home and now that I'm of age to do
so for myself my wife you know have a
baby on the way come in January
um I'm just scratching my head wondering
if it's even worth it anymore you know
where I live I can't even buy and buy
like a burnt down Shack for 350. so
that's a God's truth
well it feels a little hopeless right
now for you uh in your particular
situation and you're feeling the weight
of the responsibility of the new life
that's getting ready to come to you and
you're like holy crap this just got real
exactly yeah so all of that to say
you're you might not be ready to buy a
house today and that's okay when you're
saying your whole life you've been told
you should buy a house but do you want
to buy a house
I do want to buy a house you know the
freedom of owning it is a lot nicer than
you know we have a really good situation
we only pay 1400 a month uh which where
we live is like amazing oh yeah that's a
deal
yeah so I mean I just want to also thank
you guys because of you you know we're
able to pay off thirty thousand dollars
to steal a loan debt uh you know I could
say I'm debt free now so which is
awesome it's taken a long time to just
you know stash away and it's you know
we're about a year into the process now
good for you probably have enough well
if you don't buy a house for two years
or three years that's fine that's not
the end of the world and you're in a
very expensive market so it's going to
take you getting on top of the income
side of things and getting a good strong
down payment to make it happen let's pan
back from that and say go back to your
original question which kind of had a
hopelessness tone to it it's like is it
even worth it is it even worth it well
yeah it is worth it it's not worth doing
it stupid and it's not worth you know
buying a house you can't afford and all
that kind of stuff and this so take your
time and do it do it with wisdom but
it's worth it and here's why two things
happen with homeowner three things
happen with home ownership that make you
want to do it as a long-term play versus
renting your whole life okay number one
rents go up every year
since God was a boy rents go up every
year
I mean I've had my real estate license
since 1978 rents go up every year in
every Market they go up every year they
don't go down
and and every year and so you're gonna
have you know every year more and more
and more your money is going to go out
the door for housing and if you buy a
home and you lock down your payment
your rent doesn't go up anymore
that's wrong number one number two the
value of the house goes up
and when you're on when you rent
obviously you don't own anything that's
going up number three as we have studied
millionaires ten thousand of them we
find the primary two things that are in
their bucket that allow them to build
their first million to five million
dollars worth of work net worth is their
401K Roth IRA retirement plan in good
mutual funds like we teach and a paid
for house
that has gone up in value and so getting
to work to pay that off so it's a great
wealth building tool it stabilizes the
largest line item in your budget which
is housing
and if the largest line item in your
budget is going up every year that sucks
yeah it definitely leaves you vulnerable
but I think in your situation it's kind
of important to separate things out so
you've got your personal situation and
thinking through is this the right
timing for us and then you have you know
the market in the world and everything
like that don't let your situation and
thinking maybe you should wait a year or
to make you start getting negative about
the the market start looking at news
articles start getting hopeless I mean
it's so easy to get drugged down into
those feelings of negativity especially
when the whole news cycle is talking
about how bad real estate is and how
there's not hope for our generation and
you can't buy a house now like don't let
your feelings and fears you know get
wrapped up in what the world is saying
right now if timing for you is bad and
the market timing is bad that does not
invalidate a lifetime of real estate
ownership
the to your point those are different
things separate those out I'll give you
the first two the last one no I won't
give you this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsay trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
free stage Patrick and Heather are here
to do their debt free scream welcome
guys thank you thank you so much good to
have you where do you guys live
Rochester New York all right about an
hour away from the snowmageddon yeah
really for real you just dodged that you
sure did wow welcome to Nashville where
we don't have that yeah no it's not very
often but when we do it's it's the worst
of the worst yeah welcome guys good to
have you thank you Happy Thanksgiving to
you so you're here to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off 84
455 excellent how long did this take 26
months good and your range of income
during that time anywhere between 120
and 155 and now depending on side
hustles this year somewhere probably in
the 125 to 130 range
very good what y'all do for a living
we're both teachers
good for you well done so uh what kind
of debt was the 84 000. oh my gosh it
was like everything it was a it was a
whole bunch of normal we had some credit
cards we had a couple of cars we had
student loans there's a lot of student
loans we have very expensive brains the
Great America
the Great American nightmare right yes
indeed it truly is oh my gosh wow how
long you've been married uh almost well
it'll be four years this spring yeah
okay so after you've been married for
two years you look up and go oh uh well
you gotta change some stuff uh tell me
what happened halfway I get it you get
in the marriage thing you go whoa so
it's the second marriage for both of us
and we made far too many money issues
mistakes the first time around and
um we ended it we got married almost
four years ago and we actually lived in
two completely separate households for
the first year that we were married
because you know she had an established
home and I had an established home and
we just we couldn't put all we actually
have four children and we couldn't like
put everybody all together Under One
Roof immediately oh wow so we were like
we were saving and saving to be able to
do that and you know a year later we
finally found a home on foreclosure
because who doesn't love a good deal
um and then we like paid the closing
costs and we're going man that was a lot
of money oh gosh there's still all this
other debt oh my gosh we need to do this
God's way oh my gosh let's get going and
then we just kind of started oh wow we
were we were each kind of working
a date the proverbial davesh plan right
we were working it sort of separately
holding each other accountable and then
getting married we combined our finances
but we're still living separately
because circumstances that's just kind
of how it worked and um but the but
seeing that closing cost check go across
the table Yeah and all of a sudden
saying oh okay it's it's time that
really ratcheted up the the intensity
for us and it was it was
game on from there yeah so what did this
journey look like for you guys what did
you do to get out of debt
it's always good when it starts with a
chuckle it well it is and it's funny
because as teachers I mean we work we
don't work like the 40-hour a week no
work you know what I mean because I
teach English and he teaches chemistry
and so there's a lot of just outside
work and a lot of outside planning so it
was always kind of going oh man there's
never any time to do anything there's
never any time to do anything and I
direct the musical theater program at
our school
so that was my primary side hustle for a
while until I realized that doesn't
really pay a lot so I got another job at
Kohl's and that helped out a lot and he
was coaching and I've coached I work as
a baseball umpire so I work officially
eight games all throughout the the
region you know in the spring in the
summertime so those are the two major
side hustles we had but you know we were
like ships in the night for a long time
[Laughter]
he sold the other two houses though
right yeah we did and so then you end up
with the one the new one yep the
Foreclosure one yep okay and then it's
game on with the cars and all the mess
yeah and we were fortunate enough to be
able to finagle the from the sale being
able to pay off one car immediately yeah
and you know then the other one gets it
started it really did and it was like it
was a it was a good like Catalyst to get
the whole thing the whole thing moving
yeah it was exciting how did you connect
up with the Ramsay stuff
through well initially through church we
went through a financial peace when we
started dating and then kind of realized
we didn't want money stressors in our
relationship right and uh and now we
actually coordinate we've uh coordinated
a couple of times now yeah thank you we
need coordinators right now particularly
yeah yeah and we've enjoyed it both
times right for oh gosh and we've had
great people and we've gotten to know a
lot of really awesome people through the
whole thing we've used so you get
married buy a foreclosure combine two
households oh and there's a pandemic too
yeah that was actually that was awesome
[Laughter]
and it saved a ton of money because
there was no like oh maybe we couldn't
go anywhere in the movie maybe we'll go
do this
I had lots of time to watch YouTube
videos and figure out how to fix all the
stuff we needed to fix inside the house
so it worked out well enough
wow including your budget yeah yeah oh
yeah I mean not only do we pay off the
debt but we cash load you know
Renovations and and paid a cash for a
car when Elise ran out that was one of
the other parts of it too that got rid
of that Dad got rid of all that too yeah
but gas Providence is so awesome because
right at the time when all the used cars
because we were 100 gonna buy a solid
Dave car and then it worked out that a
solid Dave car was my three-year-old
lease that that was that was the best
deal that we could get because anything
else we were going to be paying you know
the same amount of money for something
with huge amounts of mileage and how
many owners and whatever else right so
we were like okay well I guess this is
it and then we just paid cash for that
and that was real cool and when I went
apparently people don't buy cars with
cash anymore because I went and they
were like okay what do you do you want
to finance this and I said no I have a
check and I was like the guy was like
going okay do do you need
do you need to think about this and I
said no I just want to give you the
money and then I go do people take money
here and he was like I don't know I've
never done that yeah
I don't he had been working there with
her no but he had never seen money no
and it took a while and then if you had
cash he would have turned you in as a
drug dealer well I asked him I go would
cash be easier or can I just write a
check and he's like no we don't want the
actual cash no we don't please God no no
I really wouldn't know what to do with
that right right they were so flustered
they forgot to put the tax into it so we
actually had to go back and write
another check yeah I thought I got a
deal almost I thought I got a deal
essentially we did but what a strange
world we live in when you hang with real
money is weird yeah yeah but hey we like
weird here we do like weird kids it's a
lot of fun on this side we can tell you
that yeah and now we're looking at okay
so there's only so much left on the
house so like how let's hustle through
that too yeah what do you all tell
people the key to getting out of
debt-ish oh consistency yep sacrifice
the budget the budget shared Vision yeah
this is a big part of it without that
it's it's almost impossible big deal it
really matters hey we got the live and
give bundle for you to say thanks for
coming all the way to Nashville we're so
proud of y'all thank you so much thanks
for having us well done and that's The
Total Money Makeover book the new baby
steps millionaires book both number ones
you can enjoy them or give them away
whatever you want to do and a year
subscription to our membership to
Financial Peace University you can give
that to one someone in your class
thank you so much the ability to give
and live you guys are going to be baby
steps millionaires before we know it
well done y'all that's the plan so
change in the family tree bring the
kiddos up let's introduce them in ages
and names yay this is Grace and Brennan
um both 12. ah perfect good good well
done you guys excellent excellent job
Patrick and Heather Grayson Brennan
Rochester New York area 84 000 paid off
in 26 months making 120 to 155 count it
down on let's hear a debt-free scream
three
two one
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how it's done that's the sound of
a family tree being changed oh you gotta
love it you gotta love it man I'm
telling you what hey guys speaking of
giving away stuff uh Financial Peace
University on sale for 59 the cheapest
price we've ever done for Black Friday
weekend here and you can buy it to give
away that way yeah put somebody through
the nine week class Financial Peace
University change 10 million people's
lives literally 10 million people have
been through the class now 59.99 go to
ramseysolutions.com give FPU
ramseysolutions.com
give FPU and you can give it to somebody
or give it to yourself I don't care or
give it to yourself and a bunch of
people this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Happy Thanksgiving America Christina
Ellis Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
uh this might have been
oh the last two weeks or so have been
the uh I Told You So tour
with the crash of FTX and uh everybody
losing all their little bit coinies and
I told him not to be doing it so I've
been saying I Told You So and
um
rather loudly and proudly I might add
but anyway I hate it I hate people lost
money but they really did and also let
me just rewind back to
um last spring
I told you that before the midterms that
Biden would announce some kind of debt
to forgiveness program just in time to
influence the midterms
and that he would and that when you
looked into the details of the program
you would see that it didn't amount to
much but that they would make a big
splash like they had really done
something
and they did exactly that
and everyone's talking about Biden
forgiving the student loans Biden for
giving the student loans right up into
the midterms and you notice no one's
talked about it since the election
and he came out real quietly this week
and said well you know we're going to
suspend the forgiveness program
uh until the court rules on it because
the sixth circuit court is now put a
permanent stay on it until there's an
actual court case involved it's not a no
longer a temporary stay they've just put
the quietus on this thing into that
forgiveness program so
yeah yeah Dave as I was reading this
last night I had the thought how did
Dave know like you have called it at
every stop along the way so it's what I
would have done if I were a politician
with no principles it's exactly what I
would have done because it was logical
it makes sense it was it was a very
shrewd political move
no intention whatsoever no expectation
whatsoever that the loans would actually
ever be forgiven did not notify the
Department of Education did not notify a
student dot eight dot was student go to
studentloan.gov.gov studentaid.gov major
part of the administration's
function to forgive the student loans
you didn't even tell them ahead of time
I mean if you're going to roll out a
program that's going to affect tens of
millions of people you've got to get
your staff ready for this no notice to
them whatsoever and then announces it
and that tells us right there that you
know you didn't think it's going to go
through I think it's just hard to
believe that like these are real
people's lives this is you know a
generation learning to relate to money
and learning responsibility with money
and to think that they could just you
know have all this confusion and kind of
be played with yeah be manipulated by a
politicians oh you're so sweet you never
thought that would happen I didn't want
to believe it would happen Dave
it's happening yeah and uh so federal
student loan bills have been scheduled
to resume in January of course they're
going to have trouble getting through a
house that is now a majority Republican
it's not going to happen so yeah and of
course then he gets the the next rude
move is watch this it's gonna the I
tried to do it I tried but the meno
Republicans wouldn't let me that's
that's coming next that's the thing so
Biden Administration on Tuesday
announced it will extend the payment
pause because it is the one thing they
can do on federal student loans until
after June because you should never have
to pay your bills because there's
inflation that I caused
no that isn't what they said was it okay
no that wasn't what they said uh top
official at the education department
recently said student loan default rates
could dramatically Spike if its loan
forgiveness program is supported you
think yeah ain't nobody paying these
things so the way we're not going to
admit that this uh this uh head fake on
the Forgiveness thing caused everybody
to stop paying
uh we're just gonna not make you pay
until June so that it doesn't show up
and by then you'll forget that the
reason the student loan default rates
went way up was because we told
everybody we were going to forgive them
and then we didn't oh that's that yeah
nice moves
nice move so what does all this tell you
man it's been interesting it it it's
confusing that's what it really tells
you right now it's it's kind of unfair
and confusing I actually asked a
question on Instagram last night
um just trying to get people's feelings
on it and the range is so wide it's what
was most interesting to me is even
people with student loans who are paying
off student loans are starting to get
frustrated they're like just give us
clear guidance let us know what to
expect this back and forth this it's
going to be forgiven and yet wait all of
this is just so confusing and people are
getting really frustrated oh I didn't
see this
I just saw it in the article
I thought they were extending the
payment because economic temper is so
bad no
the education secretary Cardona says in
a statement we're extending the payment
pause because it would be deeply unfair
to ask borrowers to pay a debt that they
wouldn't have to pay if it wasn't for
the baseless lawsuits brought by
Republicans
I told you they were gonna blame them
yeah we're gonna we're gonna just not
make you pay payments because the amino
Republicans are not going to do the
Forgiveness thing that's what she just
said
dang
ouch
okay moral of the story is this if you
wait on this clown show yep
both sides of the aisles together you
couldn't make a good circus if you mix
the whole thing in a stew pot okay if
you wait on this clown show if you wait
on the Island of Misfit Toys it's called
Washington DC to fix your life your life
is always going to suck
if you're waiting on a government
program to make your life shiny
your life's gonna suck
it's not their job
it's not within their power
to make your life awesome it is within
your power
absolutely and so here's a plan you took
out the loan
pay it back
you owe it
I don't know it I didn't take it out and
I'm a taxpayer and I shouldn't have to
pay your loan
a guy who
is a welder and didn't go to college and
makes 85 000 a year and work 60 hours a
week and he's out there in Sub-Zero
temperature somewhere in North America
right now welding a building together
for you to sit your little butt in
shouldn't have to pay your student loan
that's not fair
wow mic drop something to think about
but I will say if you have student loans
right now and you hear this wake-up call
and you're going man I don't want to
wait on Washington I hate this feeling
of confusion and you want to get ready
to just attack these loans this is a
great time to do it there's no interest
there's no interest pile on this is not
the time to not pay it's the time to pay
exactly they gave you more time interest
free this is a blessing in that regard
you have time without interest occurring
to pay off these student loans get it
get it knock it out another thing that's
really crazy that's happening right now
is they're sending out refund checks
have you heard about that they're
sending out refund checks in in
anticipation of forgiveness so if you're
somebody who got a refund check for
money you pay during covet do not spend
that money do not spend that money
I actually had somebody reach out on
Instagram and said that their student
loan servicer sent them a refund check
that they didn't request they didn't ask
for the money back they had paid off
their student loan and then they got a
check back in anticipation of
forgiveness
okay yeah here's a plan
yeah get these people out of your lives
they're completely incompetent and they
obviously have an agenda that has very
little to do with what's good for you
their agenda is what's good for them all
of them including these servicers all
they want to do is keep you in debt yeah
literally knowing full well it's going
to be
a while at best
and never at least well and to send out
refund checks during the holiday season
when people are already feeling a little
pressed and it's tempting to see you
know all this money in your bank account
I paid off my student loan and they sent
me a refund check oh that is maddening
I can't even get your people out of my
life when I'm trying to get you out of
my life
I know that one that one's heavy but
Charlie may just didn't want her
eviction notice she didn't want to be
kicked out navient didn't want to be put
on the street where it belongs they're
begging you to come back in they don't
want to let you go they don't want you
to be free yeah they like you they love
you they love you they think you're
great and the most toxic kind of way in
the worst kind of
find a way right oh my God they are not
your friends oh on to a better story on
December 14th we're going to do our
annual giving show where we talk about
generosity and I want to hear from some
of you that have got some great
generosity stories where you gave and it
changed someone's life and you can
Inspire other people to be generous or
whether you received and
um you've got a great inspiring story
that way send us your giving story to
ask
ramseysolutions.com ask
ramseysolutions.com for giving the
subject line and the team will be back
with you and we'll get you you lined up
for that December 14th special edition
of the Ramsey show all on giving this is
the Ramsey Show
have you been inspired
to your money
start take our three minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsesolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the pots
Moving and Storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we're dead as dumb Cassius
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Christina Ellis Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today as we take
your questions at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Happy
Thanksgiving America
take a step back and be thankful
what are you thankful for
my goodness we have so many things that
we can't even count them all so one of
your tickets are the ticket for you to
get on the show today once you make it
past Lara I was screening phones today
um
well just because Austin didn't I mean
that's how that works and so um if you
get past her your other ticket to get on
the show is uh you have to tell us what
you're thankful for well that's cheesy
Dave I know we run a cheese factory here
we're fine with that cheesy is good I
cry at Applebee's commercials so it's
okay to be cheesy all right open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five Michelle is in Green Bay
starting off this hour Michelle what are
you thankful for
um I'm thankful to God for the health
and well-being and guidance of my family
and friends and as cheesy as it sounds
I'm thankful to
Ramsay solutions for
putting out the information and guidance
that they do because I'm in a very
never thought I'd be here situation yay
touchdown hey we look we like extra
cheese on it it's good thanks very good
right well played well played so how can
we help today
so we were introduced to FPU in 2014
I've coordinated about a dozen classes
to our local church
we my husband and I have paid off 165
000 since 2014. oh wow
um that includes our house way to go
baby step seven or I know but like so
we're putting 15 into retirement we have
an ELP we're saving to beef up our
emergency fund it's only at four months
we're gonna make it six it won't take us
hardly any time at all we're saving for
a new car
um and I just received a big bump in
income while we were paying off debt we
were at about a hundred thousand now
we're at about 140 000. now what do we
do now what do we do
like we're so used to being intense and
we have an end goal that we were always
going for which was paying off the house
it's just now what do we do yeah well it
is um you do move after baby steps three
from intense to intentional
and you're just reaching a plateau that
it feels like you arrived and now I
don't have a journey and you do I still
have a journey you've just got to define
the journey now it's a New Journey
what's the next step and so you always
have to be intentional with your money
always so you always need to be looking
out a little bit and saying this is what
we're aiming at and intentional is
different than intense though
okay I've been in I've been at the
intentional stage personally with Sharon
and I for many decades now we got way
past the baby step seven stuff all that
stuff a long long time ago and um so
we've just been intentional and what
we've learned to do is there are really
only three things you can do with money
give it
enjoy it
and invest it
and I would recommend that you
systematically always with a percentage
or a dollar amount or whatever it is
you're always doing all three
and that means if your income increases
you're going to increase all three now
what has happened to us is and you're
going to be getting there someday is the
percentage that I've put towards
enjoyment lifestyle has had to get
smaller and smaller because it was
getting ridiculous
because my income was getting so high
you see what I'm saying I mean if you
put five percent of a hundred thousand
dollars towards lifestyle that's one
thing if you put five percent of you
know million whatever dollars right that
starts to be cray-cray and so
um you know you just gotta back down and
go there's only so much Lobster you can
eat right so
um and and so you but put a percentage
for lifestyle enjoying the money and
that way when you're spending that
there's no guilt
it's like I bought a nice new car but
it's a percentage of my and I've got
this other percentage towards generosity
and I've got this other percentage
towards the long-term play of investing
changing my family tree and so on right
um yeah and so uh
our giving percentage is way higher than
our consumption percentage today
and yours will get there it won't be yet
not at 140 000 even though you're 100
debt free but you can kind of see the
feel of it and so then you start to go
okay within giving with my percentages
being this it's going to be this much
money what are my goals and um uh I had
I had talked to this guy that was really
rich one time and he um he he told me
about it he gave away a million dollars
in one year
and I thought man that would be really
cool and then I did it and then I
thought well uh now what am I gonna do
okay I'm gonna give away a million
dollars in one day oh and I was able to
do that last year and so that was a kind
of a cool day and um you know oh no it
was a year before last a matter of fact
come think of it before you came before
you came on board with the show and so
but um yeah so and I'm not bragging I'm
just saying you gotta have a goal you
have something you're aiming at with
your generosity have something with you
with your net with your investing it's I
want to hit some net worth goals I want
to hit this and hit that and hit that
but having something that you're aiming
at gives it some meaning and gives some
power to your intentionality yeah hey
Michelle how do you feel about your
change in circumstances
but it's an odd feeling because we have
been so intense for so long even our ELP
has said that we need to give ourselves
a raise because it's it's almost like
we don't know how to let off yeah and
that's normal and it's just oh good
well I mean when you when you do
something really intense uh and you come
off the sports field Athletic Field it
takes two hours for your adrenaline dump
right I mean like when Christine and I
are doing stuff on stage we get hyped up
we're excited you know we got 5 000
people 2 000 people out there or
whatever on stage and we're jacked up
and we you know we cannot go back to the
hotel and go to sleep there's no chance
okay so we all get together somewhere
the whole Live Events team and we'll all
just sit around joke and cut up and and
stay up too late because we're going to
be up anyway I mean it just takes a
little while for the adrenaline dump and
that's where you are you just you're
coming off the athletic field after the
big game and
there's an adrenaline that's normal
that's normal it's wonderful it's
wonderful and I just I encourage you two
to have that celebratory whatever it is
for you guys I know you want the the
parade and the balloons but what is that
for you maybe you do balloons in a
parade in your own house something that
you can symbolically say this is a huge
achievement and now we're on to the next
one of those super super expensive
Cruises have them fill the entire room
with balloons before you get there I
like the way you think that's what
you're ought to do you gotta celebrate
it I mean you got the money and you're
not doing anything wrong you've done a
great job I'm proud of you
foreign
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
someone did not notify my marketing
department their prices are going up
because apparently for Black Friday we
have the lowest prices we've ever had
I'm so confused but okay it's great
deals for you folk our number one
bestseller of The Total Money Makeover
the audio book uh right now for Black
Friday seven dollars
plug that in listen to it on your next
trip your trip when you're going uh Over
the River and Through the Woods
Grandmother's house we go right you can
just plug the audio book in and uh
that's the way I consume them I listen
to them on my walks I listen to them
like I listen to podcasts so yeah the
new millionaire bundle comes with a
Total Money Makeover baby steps
Millionaires and the know yourself money
assessment all for 25 whoa that's a deal
and if you're looking for something a
little prettier than books the Rachel
Cruz wallet is here in Champaign
handcrafted from genuine leather looks
really good I don't know if any of the
red ones left the right ones may have
gone already so uh check those out but
the Rachel Cruz wallet a very popular
Christmas gift it really is Black Friday
deals everything all the books are ten
dollars even my latest number one we've
cut everything down
deloni was griping about the other day
because he's like he doesn't get as much
royalty when the price is down right and
he's like you guys are cutting the
prices too much well that's the way it
is all right ramsaysolutions dot welcome
to my world ramesses.com com hit the
store get the Black Friday deals
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself whyblinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings with free samples free
shipping new promos they run all the
time you'll save even more use the promo
code Ramsay and you'll get the best deal
today's question comes from Brittany in
Idaho my company matches fifty percent
up to six percent I'm currently
contributing five percent once I reach
the six percent match should I open a
Roth or get up to 15 then open a Roth or
do I stop until I pay off my student
loans I'm 36 with no kids but engaged
and hoping to have children
it's a great question and I think a lot
of people get confused they get so
excited by the match that they just
start diving into investing but if
you're still paying off your student
loans you're in baby step two so we
would tell you to hold off on investing
and focus that money on paying off the
debt he is the key is it's a temporary
pause
it doesn't you're not going to be doing
this for long your lucky student loans
out really really fast because you're
completely focus on them so when we say
stop investing
the key word is temporarily
Push pause on investing so you can
completely Focus that's a big deal yeah
and it feels a little counterintuitive
at times because the match a lot of
people are like but I'm giving up free
money it is counterintuitive it's
actually the math on it's actually wrong
it really is I mean you're giving up a
two for one match I mean 100 turns out
200 meanwhile you're just paying off a
stupid Sallie Mae it's wrong but what is
right is over the scope of your life
your most powerful wealth building tool
is your income and when you get that
back you can build wealth instead of
trying to trick something with a math so
this is also about behaviors not just
about math cleaning the deck on the St
on all the debts
it it doesn't feel right it's not fun
it's not you know unless you're around
here you don't get a touchdown you know
around here we give you a touchdown debt
free stream confetti all this stuff but
everywhere else everybody's looking at
you like you lost your mind but you when
you clear the decks you can breathe
your shoulders drop
your stress level goes down your
relationships go up your career kicks
into gear all of these things happen
none of that happens with a match yep
and that's the key is I think so many
people get focused on the math but so
much about winning with money is about
Behavior change it's not super glamorous
it's not super exciting in the beginning
but it's so that you can get to a really
awesome spot in the long run yep that's
how it works and that's why you've got
to do this stuff you got to do it you
got to do it you got to do it so
absolutely so now once you're dead free
with student loans then we start
investing then the rule of thumb is
match first Roth's second well you kind
of got that down sounds like Britney but
here's the thing you can do if your 401k
is a 401K Roth you can do 401K Roth up
to the match
and get the Roth and now the match
portion is not Roth but the rest of it's
Roth and that's what we would tell you
to do so Roth match beats Roth beats
traditional
so you always get all the match first
and then you do if you only have
traditional at the office then do
traditional up through the match then go
outside and do an individual Roth and
then if you have to do more to get to 15
go back and just do traditional but
match beats Roth beats traditional and
always do any Roth anytime you can I
mean there's very few exceptions on that
so just just do all the Roth all the
time all the can all you can and uh
whether it's at your work or whether
it's with the individual so good good
stuff Charles is with us and
Winston-Salem North Carolina hi Charles
welcome to the Ramsey Show
you too sir what are you thankful for
well actually I am thankful for my
girlfriend she's always stepped beside
me you know supporting my decision to be
something we're bone-headed and she's
actually helped me get out of debt
awesome very cool how can we help today
well a while back I ordered a new 2022
Ford Maverick I needed I needed a new
vehicles one and a half now and have a
lot of problems with and she was kind of
against it something maybe better not
get it but then just curiosity I put in
carvana see what they offer me for it
they also be seven thousand dollars more
than what I paid for it so I'm thinking
get the car
shelf carvana or like somebody another
dealership and use that money I make to
buy like a beater car you know I said
more reliable to drive for right now I
realized may have made payload taxes on
the money but so if y'all might be worth
it to do that
so you don't have that car right now
this is like you would go out and buy
the car
to sell it yeah it's it's yeah it's yeah
basically the Maverick's a very hot car
right now everybody wants what deals are
selling over MSRP but this deal is
actually selling for under MSRP because
they wanted to build their allotments up
so so I'm gonna use that money to use
our money and you're borrowing the money
to buy this car
uh yeah I did put a small down payment
on it and I got like a 1.9 uh interest
rate on it yeah the money pay cash when
the car comes in
wiped me out
yeah but I thought you're gonna sell it
the next day
yeah baseball I have to wait I have to
wait it's only two degrees because I'm
buying it from out of state
so that sent me the paper because of the
title differences from where I'm buying
it to here to North Carolina that's all
yeah and I would be able to sell it but
I'd probably spam this help like my
Christmas or right after
see I don't trust you
okay I think you're going to keep the
car
I don't want I I think you're gonna get
the car and you're gonna drive it home
and you're going
[Music]
only if I kept it
I'll kill you if you keep it
[Laughter]
but
that's going to say yeah I do sell it do
you think that
logical thing to do only if you pay cash
for it
well I can pay cash for it because what
that will do is it will make you sell it
okay because you get your stomach just
got all upset when I suggested you pay
cash for it and you're going to want to
get rid of that indigestion and you're
going to get rid of the car to get rid
of that indigestion
if you finance this you're going to keep
it
here's where I'm going all right I'm a
car guy I get it that is a sweet car by
the way it is it freaking lights out mic
drop it's a sweet vehicle now I mean I
just I and I like stuff that goes wooden
wooden I just I love things with you
know that thing will rock too it's well
it's a stupid thing 500 horse isn't it
but the Maverick yeah what's the
horsepower no it's 250 it's only 250.
it's really the 2.0 it's yeah it's
EcoBoost it's not the hybrid the
EcoBoost 250 horsepower that's awful
okay I thought I thought it had some go
all right um that makes it worse that's
like a bad chefette or something
um it's not it's not it's not a Trans Am
I thought it was a go-go I misunderstood
okay anyway aside from that I was just
that's just me talking about cars but
okay
um here's the thing
um
the reason I'm accusing you of all of
that is it's exactly what I would have
done in an earlier version of me
yeah and I'm trying to keep you from
being an earlier version of me because
he was pretty stupid
cars
what I had to figure out is and here's
what good rule for everybody out there I
had to put my I had to put things in
position to protect me from doing stupid
and when you buy this thing on payments
there's a high likelihood you're going
to keep it but if you got the
indigestion because you use your last
dime to close on it and you gotta flip
it to put your money back in your
account because you're freaking out
because you're broke that's gonna force
you to do smart and I'm trying to set up
systems here that force me to do smart
make me highly uncomfortable if I'm
being stupid and um that's what I have
to do I put automatic everything in no
stupid full smart on automatic and it
wouldn't hurt anything at all if you
just walk away from a deal by the way it
wouldn't hurt a thing this is the Ramsey
shop
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at appliance.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Matt
and Christina are with us welcome guys
welcome welcome how are you good day
thanks for being here where do you guys
live where do you all live uh we're
about 40 minutes east of Columbus Ohio
oh fun that's a nice area welcome to
Nashville how much did you pay off so
265
000 and 11 years
oh good for you and your range of income
over that decade um so baby step two
we're in the 80 80 000 range um and then
we went up during four five and six
where in the 140 180 range and I just
got a bump so about 2 18 220. now wow
good for you guys well done and uh what
do you do for a living I'm a nurse
practitioner and I work in the
electronic fraud for uh a bank yeah good
for you guys so four five six that means
this 265 included the house your debt
free house and everything it did yes yes
yeah look at that weird people that's
right yes how old are you two weirdos
38. all right man and a paid for house
what's the house worth uh well I'm now
probably about in the 300s 330 350
somewhere in there probably yeah how
much in your 401ks and retirement plans
uh total what net worth about 283. I'm
sorry 683. 683 yep yes good good you're
almost a millionaire and you're gonna be
there before you know now you're how old
again 38 38 so yeah 41 you're gonna be
millionaires yeah very good good for you
guys excellent well done well done so uh
what's what what other kind of debt was
it other than the house so uh do you
want to talk at all you want me to do it
maybe step two we sold a motorcycle we
sold or not sold well we paid it off
then sold it um and then her she had a
SUV at the time and then about 40-ish
and student loans okay between the both
of us and incredible you know her
master's degree we we funded that cash
and she's really smart so we had uh she
got a lot of scholarships
um when we were after baby step two we
pay for two cars cash I'm just bringing
all this up for that person that's you
know what I mean they get in a four five
and six just you can do it so that's
what we were we were writing our stuff
down that's you know something that we
had two kids over there that you know no
bills followed us home the bill came we
paid it off cash so so you guys were
were normal you know you're starting out
normal had different debts and then you
obviously got on fire on this journey
what did this look like for you I would
say that originally you know we were
very normal we were a young married
couple and honestly the fights that we
were having were money fights and
honestly we felt like we had really good
jobs but at the end of the day we never
seemed like we had enough
um you know we'd get the paycheck and
then it would be gone so our church
offered Financial Peace University and
we took Financial Peace and I would say
after probably maybe the third class we
were kind of like yeah we can do this
and then by the end of it we're like
we're gonna do this like we can pay off
the SUV we're like yeah it's not just
csuv it's the student loans and then
it's like okay we're on this and let's
just keep going I think that you know
we're proof that the system works um you
know following the baby steps definitely
works and I think you know being gazelle
intense for you know that first you know
30 months
um you know it's hard but then the key
now is just consistency after that it's
just sticking with the plan sticking
with what you know and then you end up
be able being able to live and give like
nobody else yeah well your numbers so
your numbers fit all the the case
studies are the millions of people that
we've talked to
um I mean exactly the average
millionaire and the millionaire uh and
the baby steps millionaires uh research
project that we did pays off their house
11.2 years you did 11 years
um you know they become millionaires
within 12 to 17 years and you're on
track to do that easily they do it by 52
years old you're not going to be
anywhere near that because you started
younger on this uh you worked debate you
worked your uh your debt snowball not
counting the house probably in less than
three years and that's that's also fits
the guy I mean that you just got you
just walk down the process I mean you
worked on the system exactly the way we
talk about way to go y'all thank you
thank you you've got to feel
accomplished it's surreal because we
went to the old place
um 30 months on baby step two we're at
the old place you know what nine years
ago yeah 2013 December 2013 we actually
did our debt free scream at that that
point in time we're like we got to go
back now we've we're baby step seven
we're going back do it again yeah do it
again yeah this was this was good a
two-stage debt free screen that's right
yes two-stage debt free Scream the other
one the old place for those of you is it
an old office before we built this
building about three years ago so they
were at the uh the old place yeah and uh
it was it was not it's nice is this this
one's nice
well you got to come see this place
people it's beautiful thank you so 11
years that's a long time to stay
committed a lot of people here 11 years
and they're like I don't know if I could
do that you know what what was the
hardest part of that Journey for you
guys I think we talked about it
consistency like when we started it was
we saw our tithing it was like
embarrassing to even talk about you know
consistent tithing and then things just
you know fall into place when we
finished off I always tell the story we
finished off baby step two we always
we'd go out Black Friday because it's
coming up we'd buy pillows on Black
Friday we sat there for for like 30
minutes picking out pillows we get to
the front and we get it was free we're
like we don't need that you know it's
like 70 worth of product at a department
store and we got it for free and was
like like we got that back I don't it's
just I share that with people that if
you as long as you keep giving keep
consistent it's gonna you know it works
so do it over time yes I also think just
remembering your why you know I think
for us we wanted to change our family
tree and be able to leave a legacy
um and I'm also someone who wanted to be
able to give you know and like he had
said you know prior to starting
financial piece you know we weren't
doing wise things with our money you
know we weren't able to live and to give
like we wanted to and so this you know
the program definitely taught us those
principles and now we've been able to to
be living proof of that yeah you guys
were fun well done I'm so proud of you
thank you thank you I mean you're 38
years old and everything's paid for Wow
how's that feel it's it's still sinking
in I guess it's very nice when you drive
into your house I walked through the
house yesterday I was like yeah this
carpet looks nice you know it's ours and
it just it feels different so you know
it does it changes everything people
don't grasp the concept because it's as
much spiritual and emotional as it is
mathematical and uh until you're
standing on that carpet and it's paid
for by God you know it changes
everything it's like man yeah it's a
it's a different level of boldness in
your life of compassion everything it's
a little just gets a little brighter out
there it's pretty cool those shades are
off yeah well done you guys very very
well done sharp young couple man heroes
well done guys all right you took
control of your life we got the live and
give bundle for you for you to give away
the uh uh Total Money Makeover book
which obviously is a core piece and
you'll be able to give that to somebody
Financial Peace University membership
you'll be able to give that to somebody
you guys have uh been through the class
coordinated the class thank you for all
of that very cool and the baby steps
millionaires but because that's your
next chapter in your story for sure so
you just keep on rocking guys keep on
rocking I love it let's bring the kiddos
up what are their names and ages we have
Kinsey who
all right debt-free kiddos yeah do they
know what's going on they do we've been
prep we practice the whole way down here
they've been practicing for months
probably right okay and they know what
this means you their mom and dad are
heroes they change their lives well done
you guys very very well done Matt and
Christina from Ohio 265
000 paid off house and everything
11 years did it make an 80 all the way
up to now 218. count it down let's hear
a debt free scream
three two one
[Applause]
you know little Luke is old enough to
remember that time his weirdo parents
drove all the way to Tennessee to that
strange radio show
and did their debt-free Scream that time
they paid off their house that time that
they never borrowed any money again that
time that their whole lives were changed
he's old enough to remember his mom and
dad being Heroes that's powerful I mean
that's the sound of a you you guys if
you listen go back and listen to that
again if you're listening to it on
podcast rewind and listen to it you just
heard the sound of a family tree
changing right in front of you this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Ty number one best-selling author is my
co-host today
charnise is with us in New York City Hi
charnise how are you
Hi how are you better than I deserve how
can we help
happy holidays by the way Happy
Thanksgiving so what are you thankful
for
I am actually thankful for a lot but um
family friends I just recently moved to
a co-op so I'm happy about that and my
career good for you cool how can we help
today
yes so um I live of course in New York
City I'm 34 years old I'm a social
worker and I have a son who's to Chisel
right now I only have one stream of
income and I have 300 roughly around 300
uh thousand dollars worth of debt this
is also including student loans credit
cards Etc and I'm trying to prioritize
what to focus on first it's bringing on
a lot of anxiety
um I do make about 60 I believe 65 I got
a raise today actually and so I'm just
trying to figure out how I can be debt
free in a short amount of time take care
of you know my son had some saving I
can't save for anything and just live
comfortably uh that's the biggest thing
for me I did file for bankruptcy in 2018
and I was fine until I recently moved
this year
and uh the credit card debt stacked up
because of the move and I had some
medical issues so you know this year has
been really tough uh and now I'm
struggling kind of
well we're glad you called that's first
step I feel like the way you're
describing that you've had your I've had
it moment
is that right yeah definitely yes you're
done with the stat you're ready for
something new
totally I just want to of comfortable I
want my son to have his savings where
did you move from
well I'm actually from New York City but
I moved from a studio
uh building so you're broken deeply in
debt and you're increased your rent
yes I did
but you're broken deeply in debt and you
can't breathe
oh and you run a credit card debt to do
that too
as of this summer yes it went up
yep
okay let's back out for a second
um
I can help you
all right but this is a math problem at
its core
and there's two pieces of information
here there's your income
and there's your debt load and around
here we call that the shovel
and the hole
you have a very large hole
and a medium-sized to small shovel
agreed
agree thus the anxiety
thus the stress the overwhelming feeling
the sense of hopelessness the sense I'm
going to be stuck here forever I can't
breathe I don't see a way out
I've been there I know how it feels
okay so you have a pretty radical
situation
a very difficult situation that you find
yourself in with the math
would you agree with that too
yeah definitely the sad news is and um
we love you enough to tell you the truth
kiddo
uh the sad news is radical difficult
situations require radical difficult
Solutions
and the only way to get out of this
highly
toxic math is to do some bizarre things
that are going to be very uncomfortable
in the short term you don't get an
option
there's no option on the table where you
get to do three things
make sixty five thousand dollars a year
have a wonderful life and live in
Manhattan
these three things and and get rid of
300 000 of the debt these three things
these things don't work in the same
puzzle they don't fit together
okay so Something's Gonna Give
something's going to give
the you're going to give up the cool
cozy wonderful life you're going to do
some crazy things to increase your
income
um you're not going to live in Manhattan
I don't know
but you can't do what you're doing right
now it's not going to work in the next
two decades
you're still going to be in debt
because I can back this out and just
tell you if you had zero debt living in
Manhattan with a child as a single mom
on 65 000 is no picnic if you had zero
debt that's no picnic
agreed
I agree and you got 300 000 bucks
sitting on top of your head
and uh it ain't going away
unless you make it go away so I I wish I
didn't
um
so I I think you're going to pick your
pain
or it's going to pick you
um you're gonna pick your pain you're
going to say all right we are going to
live in a different situation for a
short period of time and it's going to
be very uncomfortable for me and my
child and the hours I'm going to work
are going to be freaking ridiculous so
that we can have a great life later
we're going to live like no one else so
that later we can live and give like no
one else or you're going to choose to
stay exactly where you are and this
stuff's going to come crashing down on
you because this math does not work it's
not sustainable
you can't you can't pay for a co-op in
Manhattan on 65k and service 300 000 you
can't even pay the payments
and eat well
uh so the maintenance fee so I do live
in the Bronx the borough is the Bronx
and I had to God alone because it was 33
000 so it's like pretty much it helps
middle income uh individuals with a
co-op and so I put a little bit down and
I'm paying it off
um slowly I think I have like seven
years to pay off the loan that they gave
me
and then of course I have my Cardinal
credit card debt and student loans
private school loans as well
you bought the co-op
yeah so I I bought the car and you have
a seven year loan on it
yeah well I can pay it off at any time
but I put a down payment on it
um it's it's like a program that helps
you uh pretty much are you telling me
you're gonna have to call it paid off in
seven years
I they add on the extra from the loan to
the maintenance fee yeah
yeah but I mean what happens at the end
of seven years you've got to go get a
mortgage right
it is pretty much a mortgage I am a
whole
and you have it on a seven year payout
in the Bronx
I calculated it and I believe that's how
much it's gonna how long it's gonna take
for me to pay off that phone that they
gave me to cover the other half so
what was the price
uh altogether that Co-op apartment was
33
750. that was the price to buy a co-op
in the Bronx
yes
I am so confused I would have said 3.3
million
how did you get it for 33 000 are you
sure
yeah so it's pretty much like I said
it's a program in New York City that
helps the middle uh income uh
individuals and they pretty much
um assist so you have to come up with
the whole you have to come up with the
whole amount and if you can't come up
with the whole amount uh then you can go
on a payment plan and then they'll add
it to your maintenance fee it's called a
maintenance fee this is the most
Heavenly program I've ever heard of
where you can buy a co-op in the Bronx
for 33 000 bucks my mind is blown okay I
had no idea that this is even possible
or existed I am still in shock and awe
so anyway I guess I'll set that aside if
you got that deal I'll let it rest I
have never heard of that and it's
mind-blowing and it's has nothing to do
with real estate values in the area
nothing to do with that whatsoever you
can't buy that in anywhere in America
much less the freaking a borough of New
York one of the 18 boroughs in New York
City not a chance okay so all right I'll
let that rest we still have the 300 000
in debt well and I still have a problem
and I'm I'm worried you know when you
first picked up there's a lot of remorse
in your voice there's a lot of angst so
I thought you had that I had it moment
but I'm a little worried that the
bleeding's still going like have you cut
up your credit cards yet
I mean 300 000 that is that's a
terrifying amount on that on that income
and so sharnice I don't want us to run
out of time here's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna put you on how Laura's gonna pick
up we're gonna put you through Financial
Peace University as our guest because I
don't know how to help you on this call
today uh there's too much going on here
but you have a problem and the problem
is you don't make enough to pay this
debt off in a reasonable period of time
so something's got to give
on the income side of the equation and
it may mean you live in an entirely
different area of the nation unless you
bought a condo from a co-op
wow that's amazing okay cool hey good
good hour yeah thanks for hanging out
Happy Thanksgiving everybody this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the pots
Moving and Storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Christina
Allen's number one best-selling author
and Ramsay personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five we're going to go
to GT in Roanoke Virginia to start this
hour hi GT how are you
oh I'm I'm all right a little a little
nervous and a little concerned after
checking my credit statement the other
day okay what's up
well I've got over 500 000 in debt and
um I'm getting ready to sell a house but
I just don't know what to do with the
money and I'm worried I made a mistake
okay five hundred thousand dollars in
debt on what
um thirty thousand dollars in truck uh
35 000 on land at the lake
135
000 on the house that we're getting
ready to sell and 350 000 on the house
we just bought okay and what's your
household income
uh 160 to 180 depending on over time
okay all right
yeah I would encourage you to separate
out the debt when you're kind of looking
at it because that is overwhelming when
you're having all of your PR the 350 is
your primary mortgage right
yes it is now we're moving into that one
within the month tell us a little bit
about the house you're about to sell
with a 135 that you mentioned how much
Equity is in that house
uh we've got it under contract for 260.
okay so what did you you've already
closed on the house this 350 that's your
main house right and that's your old
house right
the 350 is the one that we closed on
that we're moving into the other one the
whole house yes how much did you put
down we haven't closed
the 350.
uh none
but you're sort of uh
go ahead go ahead how did you do that
um it was a situation where it was about
to be foreclosed on and it was a great
deal it's probably worth five five fifty
and
um we just we the foreclosing Bank
wouldn't allow us to make a contingent
on selling our own home right and so you
just went got a bank loan
yes okay is that is the 350 now on a
permanent mortgage or is it still a bank
loan
permanent okay all right so you're set
up then the other house is sold when you
sell it you've got the money to pay off
the truck and uh the other 35 000 right
yes and you'll be debt free other than
your home
yes okay where's the overwhelm part
uh just seeing half a million dollars in
debt I've never had that much before in
my life okay
so you're doing all this two-step and
you just didn't look at how many
different squares you were stepping on
yeah I guess so yeah and but now once
you finish the dance
it's not overwhelming anymore really
no no I guess not I mean you got 350 000
household house payment that's it
you've got
um another sixty thousand dollars laying
in your checking account that we need to
set some aside for your rainy day funds
your emergency fund let's call that 35
000 and that gives you 30 000 to put on
some other stuff
um maybe get your retirement and your
kids college started with some of that
um and so the the end of the end of the
story turns out the the wake-up call and
the lesson to be learned it sounds like
is that
the way you went at this left you more
vulnerable than you like to be and I
would agree with you
yeah yeah because there was a moment
here
and we're kind of still sitting in it at
this moment until this house closes the
first house closes there's a moment here
where you're 550 000 in debt and if it
went sideways you'd be messed up
yeah like if the market froze up and you
couldn't sell that other house you'd be
up a Creek right now
yeah yeah I would and so the good news
is it sounds like you're going to get
out by the hair of your chinny chin chin
and end up in actually a good place but
the good news is it scared you enough to
make you concentrate more next time you
were faced with a similar
opportunity to hide the pee under a
shell
is that am I missing something
no no you're spot on I just like I said
you know once the numbers hit me it you
know it scared me and I was like what if
something goes wrong yep good and
remember that feeling yeah and so next
time you go I you know because I don't
enter I used to do stuff like that all
the time and and until I took my dadgum
head off and I'm you know walking around
you know like a Halloween costume or
something looking for my head it was
gone it just knocked it off and I'm like
geez man my whole life got turned upside
down here I just about I lost everything
I just about lost my marriage I lost
about it destroyed my whole freaking
world and so I don't ever I don't even
go close to that stuff anymore and so
that can be your lesson like I kind of
overstepped here
you know I I like I was walking along
the edge of the cliff and the Rocks were
falling off and I acted like they
weren't and I was singing and whistling
a tune and and I made it back like safe
but I'm not going to take that path
again I don't like being that close to
the edge and that's a good lesson so
just learn the lessons GT that's all I
would tell you yeah and then just use
that the lessons you've learned to
continue forward being responsible with
your finances stay away from the edge of
the dadgun flip right right exactly
that's really what it has come down to
so very very good question and
um so it's a good example and you know
his emotion came up and caught him but
if this had gone sideways and but now
that it's turned out it's really going
to leave him in a very good place a very
reasonable place he's debt-free
everything but his house 350 000
mortgage 180 000 income that's not out
of line this is all very doable okay he
ends up in a good place but this is an
example of when he started this process
he doesn't know that's going to turn out
and that's what caught him and took his
breath away
most people don't even bother to have
their breath taken away they just go oh
that's what I planned and that's what
happened here's the debt only works or
buying two houses at one time only works
or doing anything only works when it
works
and most of the time life doesn't work
exactly the way you had it planned
and so that's when it gets your dad gum
head taken off and that's where you get
to experience the borrower as slave to
the lender and a foolish man devours all
he has and um in the house of the wise
our stores of choice food and oil and
these Bible verses that talk about
living on lesson you make having an
emergency fund having a plan and not
being in debt and
that you know that plan works in good
times and in bad times and so uh we had
a call in an earlier hour today where I
told a guy do not buy the second house
until the first one is sold remember
that same same scenario here because you
can get caught now good news is GT got
out I'm happy for him happy he didn't
learn the lesson except put his stomach
in his throat without having to learn
the lesson you know that's good that's
good I'm happy that there's no harm no
foul uh I don't wish bad things on
people what I try to do is help you
avoid setting yourself up where bad
things can get you don't let them get
you it's Halloween this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Christine Ellis Ramsey personality is my
co-host today best-selling author Ramsay
personality last week we announced our
spring Building Wealth live tour and
tickets are really selling fast the VIP
tickets in Indianapolis and Anaheim sold
out within 48 Hours the Building Wealth
live events are going to walk you
through a simple but proven plan that
will help you save money build wealth
and make smart decisions in this crazy
economy what's happening out there
despite what the news and the internet
say it is still possible join me Rachel
Cruz Ken Coleman Dr John deloney George
Campbell for a night of Hope and
normalcy this spring the tour dates
available today Indianapolis February
16th Austin Texas February the 23rd and
Anaheim on May the second tickets start
at 39 dollars our fall events sold out
in days you do not want to wait on this
go to ramseysolutions.com events to get
your tickets and particularly you better
get them like today if you want VIP or
platinum on any of these they go first
and they go early and they go really
really fast our question of the day is
from blinds.com they have a 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure or you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your window blinds
for free free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
Ramsay to get the best deal today's
question comes from Trish in Missouri
our son graduated from high school in
2021 he decided to use his scholarships
working income and a small subsidized
Federal Loan to pay for college so far
he has done an amazing job with his
finances he had 17 700 saved for him and
his 529 but he wanted to leave it alone
and use it for his late years of school
when he might need it even more the 521
529 was doing so well we neglected to
look at the funds he was in and move it
to safer funds as he got closer to 18
years old it grew to 18 700 by 2022 but
has dropped significantly to 14 800 as
of today we realize now this was a
mistake now with less than three years
of college left the market still looking
Grim do we move it and cut our losses
tell him to use it all that he can now
or just wait it out also Missouri where
our 529 is as of right now will not let
us use 529 to repay back loans later
thanks for the advice hmm
this is interesting I I feel like the
first thing I would do is just kind of
talk to you guys about your mindset I
mean you're saying that he's taken out
federal uh subsidized student loans so
far and that he's also doing great with
his finances I think the fact that even
debt was on the table to begin with
isn't great you had a 529 available and
then you still took out a student loan I
kind of would just challenge you first
and foremost to go let's let's not do
debt like let's first establish that
mindset and take it off the table and
then explore options from there I think
if that was kind of a conversation from
the beginning you probably would have
used the 529 earlier on and he wouldn't
have taken out a loan
um but Dave I'm curious about your your
thoughts on this because we're never
going to tell you to take out a lot
exactly period okay so now we got to
figure it out because here's what taking
out a loan is in this situation if
you're taking out a loan so that you can
leave this alone and let it come back up
that's like saying I'm going to borrow
14 800 hoping and invested in the stock
market hoping it will go up
well you would never do that that's
Dumber in a rock
and so no we're not going to do that
we're not going to take out a loan in
order to give this time to ride back up
what we are going to do is put Junior to
work
yeah w-o-r-k
I want him busting it and uh I want him
you know using Christina's materials and
applying for scholarships like a
bazillion of them
I don't aim to apply apply apply apply
apply I want him working all the time
and um
then the other question I've got is
where is he in school
you know I was in an expensive school
you can't afford so in other words if
you want to leave this money alone and
let it come back up which is a good idea
actually
the only way to do that is find the
money to pay for school
because three years if he's got three
years left that's a lot of time it's
gonna come back up right and you've got
to find the money anyway because this is
not enough to get him through school
well and if they continue going forward
with the way they're going forward three
years of taking out loans is going to
add up to a lot of money like you're
saying that it's a good he's done well
with his finances so far but three more
years of taking out loans that's not
going to be good so it's amazing the
creative options you come up with when
you take debt off the table he's going
to have to maybe look at what schools he
at can he go to a cheaper school is
there some sort of employer he can work
for that has a tuition assistance
program what scholarships are out there
can he talk to the financial aid office
and see if they can offer him anything
else like when you don't have debt as an
option then you really start fighting
for yourself and trying to figure out
what are the most strategic ways for me
a ton of these retailers like Target for
instance and others are if you're
working a certain number of hours
they're so desperate they're willing to
pay tuition
legit and so yeah go that that and that
changes the numbers on what you're
making while working there I mean you
might be making 18 you might be making
22 an hour and getting free tuition
potentially thousands of dollars in
tuition like that is a lot of benefit
right there plus you're building your
resume I mean you may be starting in a
basic retail position but maybe you can
be a manager by the time you graduate so
if you're not going to borrow any more
money for the next three years you've
got to figure out how do I pay a way to
pay for college anyway
so while you're doing that that gives
you also time to let this money grow
back before you cash it in yep because
I'll tell you that in 12 months I think
you'll be fine it's gonna be back
that's my guess might be 18.
might be 18. but bear markets there's
very few bear markets would have lasted
longer than that when you start this
process the spare Market started
basically at the first of this year
and a four-year bear Market is almost
non-existent in history there's almost
none of them
and so you know two years you're going
to be fine 18 months you're going to be
fine something like that you're going to
make some money on this money but the
the point is you've got to have some
money anyway to get through school
without debt and so we need to go find
that money from working from
scholarships I went for work
scholarships whatever it is we're doing
and from school choice uh and so forth
so you've got a lot of work to do period
across the board and the book is debt
free degree it is in the Ramsey store at
ramseysolutions.com and it will help you
with this process and Austin if you can
figure out who this person is and how to
send it to them go ahead and send them
one okay I don't know whether what our
connectivity is on all these questions
that come in by email and other things
so but if you can do that get him out
get him one out I'll get her and one out
I guess and but yeah the
it's almost like uh we're doing good
with our money while we borrow student
loans is as dumb a statement as I don't
have any debt oh wait I've got student
loans yeah that's debt
it's just those are both dumb statements
people keep saying that student loans
it's good debt and people just seem like
that that for some reason God people are
starting to realize this bad debt I mean
it's so bad the president has to forgive
it
but still keep giving out loans yeah
well thank you for that that's good yeah
and she you ruined the whole thing there
Robert's with us or Robert is in uh New
Hampshire hey Robert what's up
hi guys thanks for taking my call sure
um so me and my wife have been on a
credit card with 35 to 37 000 for the
last 15.
2 20 years
um wondering if poem
from my 401k to pay that
is smart or not well you if you don't
change your habits you go right back in
debt wouldn't you
correct so we don't have we don't have a
credit card problem we got a habit
problem
yeah we're just the one credit cards
everything else has been good and we
have a minimizing problem
yes
you call me up because you're stressed
out about your credit cards and you're
well it's just one okay which one is it
is it a problem or isn't it okay
so no we're not cashing out your 401K
for two reasons one is you got to change
you
and that's the best answer for your
long-term wealth building and two is if
you cash out your 401K they're going to
charge you a 10 penalty plus your tax
rate so you're going to get hit 30 to 40
percent and so that's like saying hey
Dave I want to borrow money at 30
interest pay off my credit card I would
of course say no and you would even say
no to that Robert so no we're not doing
it
so the question I'm actually asking do I
take a loan out against myself no no no
no no no you can't borrow your way out
of death sir doesn't work can't get out
of a hole while you're digging out the
bottom it's time to address Robert
look in the mirror say you're the
problem
in the mirror say you're the solution
hold on I'm going to send you a book
called Total Money Makeover that's
helped 10 million people fix what you
need to fix this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today number
one best-selling author in the lobby of
Ramsey Solutions on the debt free stage
Brian and Valerie are here hey guys how
are you doing great we're doing awesome
welcome good to have you guys how much
where you guys live Denver Colorado cool
welcome to Nashville thank you how much
have you paid off well married we paid
off 160 000 in 22 months and single or
altogether we paid off 205 and 34 months
okay before the 22 months started or is
that total including everything uh
that for the 22 months so the total is
more like uh 365
000. or it's 205 total in 34 months oh
okay that's the total that's what I was
there okay all right so that's a good
good good good good good all right and
so uh during the 22 months what was your
range of income it was 213 to 273. all
right very cool what do you guys do for
a living
and I'm a manager for an engineering
firm uh for a cad manager ah okay very
cool kind of figured out how you two met
okay and so um all right and uh so we
had 205 000 total yes and started
working on it before we're married
finished it after we're married tell us
the story how did all this work yeah so
I it started in August 2020 so right or
yeah 2020 right before the pandemic and
uh
or August 2019 and I was in interning as
an engineer before I got my first job
and my good friend Mark who is a marine
reservist just want to point that out so
you can imagine how uh intense he is but
he came into my office and kept trying
to get me to do this Ramsay thing in
this FPU class I was like no I'm fine
I'm fine and uh finally two weeks before
the class started he came in and he
closed my door and was like why won't
you take this class
and I was I I think I just broke down
crying
yeah
I just broke down
and uh this is like illegal right here
this is how we do in the armed forces so
he I kind of opened up to him and uh
my family we'd lost four people in four
years
um
and
dealing with PTSD I just gotten out of
the military and I was broke I was in
six figures of debt and I just I was
scared and ashamed and I was making less
than 40 000 with six figures of debt so
and he could see your eyes yeah and he
convinced me to take it and I was pretty
resistant for six weeks it was until the
seventh class that I was like okay I
know you are a hard case
I mean usually first or second class I
guess I mean seven classes I was so
angry especially about the student loans
I was convinced I couldn't go to college
without student loans
that gets you started on the whole thing
and then poor Brian wanders into the
story
it was our first date I was talking
about it and I was like yeah if you're
not on board I'm just not sure about
this you know so our FPU classes became
date night and uh it was the only way I
kept got to keep seeing her so
you went from I'm not going I'm going to
cry about it too uh we're not even going
on a second date if you're not in dude
yeah wow that's this is a one seventh
class was thorough I mean at least the
conversion was thorough but then she was
all in yeah then I was all in and then
some and I think it was Chris Hogan it
was three years ago I think he was in
that one yeah his deep voice just really
got me he was like oh I need to do this
yeah so it's very command it is
commanding very cool good for you guys
so you you finally get convinced and
then you get started what did the
Journey of paying off the debt look like
um it had its ups and downs
um you know we stuck together and uh we
did our our first budget meeting
um that was that was fun that was six
hours yeah
um six hours yeah I'm a state right yeah
this is two Engineers all right so I'm a
nerd with a spreadsheet he did not give
up the spreadsheet no no not at all and
then um it became easier once we kind of
jumped into the full like we're all on
board we're not doing a Davis
um we got the every dollar app and so
that I had to release control of my
spreadsheet and um devastated I think it
was but it was it was totally worth it
and you know us being a new married
couple
um financials can be a real struggle and
a real stress on the marriage but
um we went into it knowing we were on
the same plan and uh it just made it's
made our marriage so much more
successful and wonderful
who are your biggest cheerleaders in the
process
well our best friends Lisa and JT came
with us today way to go guys yeah um and
then our FPU coordinators I think
they're listening right now Mary and
Mark oh that Mark was the coordinator
yes yes oh okay he's recruiting for the
class I mean he was all in so I love it
way to go Mark yeah that's awesome so so
you truly experience that resistance and
now yes you are here you went all in you
paid it off so if you were in Mark's
position and you're I mean you're in his
position right now there are people
listening who feel that same level of
resistance what would you tell them
well I would just tell them for someone
like me who I just I was so I just
thought I was so strong and I could do
this all on my own and
um I was too ashamed and embarrassed
um
to and too prideful to think that I was
doing something wrong and so I just I
think the biggest thing is to be humble
enough to put your pride down
and uh if it's not working for you try
something new
so good yeah it's not like it's your
identity I mean right yeah but people
treat it so yeah we hold on to it was
such a tight fist we do yeah and so that
that whole part of your journey is
actually more beautiful than the paying
off of the debt
I've changed completely
um I was so resistant and so hard-headed
and
now it just feels like I'm a different
person you had so much loss yeah and and
then you had some anger to go with it
yes and you should yeah you had quite a
little chemistry thing going on here I
had a lot going on a little chemistry
sex a little chemistry set going on here
I was just mad all the time yeah yeah
and and then you just aimed you're mad
at the right thing yes and knocked it
out yeah and that there is something
that sets you free when you do that
that's very powerful yes very cool you
guys are you guys are a neat couple and
uh what you've been through and what
you've been through together is very
very very strong very you're set up to
win at an unbelievable level now because
not only that but you probably heard us
say that in the millionaire study that
we did the number one uh career choice
of millionaires is engineer and you're
and we have two of them here
yeah and you've been through FPU and
you're thoroughly thoroughly thoroughly
converted by less than seven oh my God
yes yeah I still I still can't get over
that but yeah it's good what a way to
start your marriage like you can just
tell by the way I'll look at each other
that you're so connected yeah yeah
that's just powerful
I love it hey we got a copy of The Total
Money Makeover for you you'll be able to
give that away as you continue to uh
tell people what has happened in your
life we're so proud of you you guys are
amazing amazing couple and of course
baby steps millionaires because that's
the next chapter in your story you're
right on your way to that and a uh one
year membership to Financial Peace
University that you can give away as
you're talking about it so the live and
give bundle is just for you guys we're
so proud of you very very very well done
all right if you got to tell people one
thing or two things they got to do to
get out of debt what do you tell them
um I everybody says it's a budget but I
mean it's true you have to stick to it
and don't everybody has a mountain to
climb we we all have doesn't matter how
small or how large it is
um
we all have to do it and so just stick
with it uh stay on the path and you'll
climb that
it's uh one bite at a time right the
elephant that's how you eat the elephant
beautifully done well done Brian and
Valerie Denver Colorado what a great
story 205
000 paid off single and married over 34
months making 213 to 273. count it down
let's hear a dead free scream three two
one
[Applause]
I gotta keep you coming back I love it
baby
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Romans 14 17 for the kingdom of God is
not a matter of eating and drinking but
of righteousness peace and joy in the
Holy Spirit Mark Twain said to get the
full value of joy you must have someone
to divide it with
ah well done Mark Twain Mark Twain the
Romantic who knew hey folks if you like
this show please do us a favor we need
three favors from you one is subscribe
on YouTube subscribe on the podcast
number two leave a review that would be
a five-star review we don't really need
your one Stars thank you very much and
share it with a friend tell somebody
listen tell somebody jump in be part of
the program be part of a tell them what
it's done for you I mean that young
couple there we got to meet them at the
break absolutely amazing and uh just
powerful stories and uh you guys on
radio
YouTube gets a little bit of glimpse of
it but on radio you didn't get to see
her eyes I mean it just lit up I mean
she's just on fire and uh they they you
know they again they
Financial Peace University
um the podcast that you know the whole
thing and
um and now they're
uh I mean what would you pay to get rid
of 205 000 worth of debt
it's 99 to go through FP I mean this is
like a good trade this is a very good
Roi yeah that's a good Roi Daniel is
with us in Mobile Alabama hi Daniel how
are you hey I'm great it's uh honor to
be on with you well thank you sir how
can we help
I've got a I've got two questions my
first question is
the way the market is today
I've lost roughly 60 000.
you know yeah I've got a Vanguard Target
retirement account
my question is to stop the bleeding
so you got like a half million dollars
in it
no I had about 225
thousand in it
and I lost 60 000 since when
uh
since about a year in the past year
well the Market's down 13 that wouldn't
be sixty thousand on 220.
well I'm down about 160. wow oh you're
down about 60 you set go down to 160
I've seen okay yeah yeah okay all right
um I got my question I've been listening
to a lot of things on the radio and I've
talked to a few people what is your
opinion about indexed annuities
would I be would there be any advantage
to go into something like that just to
stop the bleeding yeah it's too late
I mean you're not stopping the bleeding
unless you think it's going to continue
to bleed out and I don't
um and so the only person that gets hurt
on a roller coaster is one jumps off in
the middle of the ride
and so
um you know uh I'm I'm not sure that I'm
a fan of uh your initial selection of
funds
um but how old are you
six and six okay I'm 62 and I have mine
across four types growth growth and
income aggressive growth and
international and in the last 12 months
the stock market and the Dow Jones has
lost about 13 percent and that's about
what I'm down is about 13 you're down
more than 13 percent
it's what you're telling me so
um I would not move it to indexed
annuities I don't have a diamond indexed
annuities
um and uh
so do you need the money today no okay
um you've got other money yes okay
what's it in
um well
I'm retired
so I've got my teacher retirement I've
got an associate Social Security
um I'm debt free
except
if I say a debt
um helping pay for law school for one of
my my daughter okay
so that's really the only thing that I
have that's your only nest egg
uh yes and you're living off of your
teacher pension and stuff okay yeah okay
now I've got
I had about 75 000 just in savings that
I've been putting some take diverting
some to there to be ready for the Law
School tuition good okay that's fine
yeah that's where it should be that's
good all right um well the the Target
Fund that you have or the target funds
that you have what's the track record on
them long term how old are they
I can't answer that okay I got in about
20.
about 2014.
okay so you've been you've been in eight
years and it's not been a problem it's
just this particular downturn you really
took it on the chin yeah you've written
out a couple other downturns so yes like
spring of 2020 remember that it dropped
like crazy
remember that
for the most most of the time I don't
even look at it okay all right well if
you go back and look
your your fund most funds dropped
substantially around the coveted
quarantine hit
and then they came back in September
or back to where they were they're back
even but a lot of people jumped out with
that down downturn because they're
freaking out over everything over covet
right
um and so right now we got a Biden freak
out going on or whatever you want to
call it inflation freak out
um
and uh corporate profits are down and so
stocks are down
and um because inflation's putting the
squeeze on the profit margins as well as
causing prices to go up so um
ah Daniel no index funds I would not do
to answer your question what I would do
is sit down with a smartvester pro and
um let's do a little bit of learning
because I'm not sure I can answer your
question on it without I want to go back
on this Target Fund and say I've got to
get comfortable with the history of it
that its recovery rate is about as good
as the Market's recovery rate if I get
comfortable with that I'm probably just
going to leave it alone
if I'm uncomfortable that this is a good
selection and I need to move it into
some other funds I'm going to move it
from one set of funds that are down to
another set of funds that are down that
have a better recovery rate when the
market turns up
I got you that's what I would do but no
the index fund is mythology because it
has to ride the other stuff too it's
indexed off the stock market that's what
it's indexed off of and they put some
checks and balances in there in charge
of double commissions uh to where you
think you've got your principal
protected and other stuff it's an
insurance product and so I I wouldn't
screw with it I don't put any money in
that kind of stuff I just ride these
waves and the good news is you don't
have to have the money and you can
afford to ride the wave what you need is
and what I would need if I were you and
I'm asking you to get this is some
intellectual
um
comfort
that the recovery rate on this fund when
the stock market recovers is reasonable
that it's going to come back as the
market comes back meaning that the fund
is riding the market waive not just a
bad fund
um and it's scaring me because it's down
further than the market pretty
substantially so that's why I want you
to look at that if you told me you were
off 13 I'd say I just tell you sit tight
write it because that's what the
Market's off
but when you're down more than 13
percent in in 12 months then if you're
down from 220 to 160 in that period of
time then there's something else going
on here and I want to look at that this
this may be a more volatile fund which
might mean it might recover faster
actually so you just need to learn the
fun so jump on ramseysolutions.com click
on Smart investor Pro and learn because
Christina the trick with this is history
is the only shot you've got at getting
some comfort
on these things I mean if you look at a
phone that's got an 80-year history like
I've owned one that's 80 years old okay
and I can go back and go it's got 11.2
percent rate of return for 80 freaking
years and it's down 13 I can kind of be
calm you know history gives me Comfort
right
um but but if if I if I don't know those
things then it's harder to be calm yeah
and I think this is such an important
conversation right now to have because I
think a lot of gen Z Millennials who
this is their first time writing out you
know a bear Market a rough Market it's
just important like you said The only
person who gets hurt on a roller coaster
is the person who jumped off you know
it's just important to be able to look
historically you know what are these
markets like and then just look at the
funds and see the history see the track
record and then have peace As you move
forward and not freak out and jump off
the great news is that Daniel can live
on his pension and he can just leave
this alone and it can afford to let it
ride back up that's the great news in
this call so very well done very well
done that puts this hour the Ramsey Show
in the books our thanks to Austin Ben
Zach Andrew and James in the booth I am
Dave Ramsey Christina Ellis my co-host
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsesolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]